hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between body's facilities basket and the
Robert James Fisher this is game 15 and
yes it is 1 million and two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that is how much
money mr. Chester Fox will not be making
due to the match not being filled ever
filmed
but Fischer did get a lot of offers on
how he could make such an amount of
money for example he was offered a
six-figure sum by a film company from
California it was supposed to be a movie
a spy murder mystery based on each guess
which Fisher declined then also he was
offered to do a commercial on a hair
lotion product which he as he does have
very nice hair maybe maybe not as nice
as possible it is a very nice hair
but he also declines the decline this as
he said that he never used it so how
could he you know advertise it and there
were also some other ideas about how he
could make that much money to make up to
me to make it up to mr. Chester Fox if
he at some point does sue him I even you
know doing autographs and then perhaps
selling them and those were mostly ideas
by his lawyer but now for the time being
that has been put aside as we do have
game 15 to be played and Fisher
complained about a lot of other things
for example air conditioning people in
the audience who were more and more
seeking for autographs and he requested
that the game 15 will be played in the
back room but as a lot of Schmidt knew
that there was no way in hell that
Spassky would agree to this he simply
declined Fischer's offer and game 15 was
again planed played on the main stage so
once again
Spassky is down three points in the
match and he does have to start winning
games so there's no time to fool around
he plays efore and Fischer he tried a
lot of things here even the idea his
defense but now he goes back to c5 the
Sicilian defense and it will be very
interesting if you will go for the
poisoned pawn variation once again
Knight to f3 by Spassky b6 B for C cap
first night captures Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and a6 the night or variation is
on the board Bishop to g5 and now e6 and
okay we have f4 and here alike in the
famous in game 11 where Fischer played
Queen to b6 and went for the poisoned
pawn variation here Fischer declines the
poisoned pawn variation and he plays
Bishop to e7
so the standard night off we have Queen
to f3 by Spassky Queen to c7 and now we
have queenside castle and Knight bt7 by
Fischer it's interesting if you if you
try and go for this b5 expansion on the
Queen side too early it could be very
dangerous because of this 'if I've break
through attacking the knight and also
the rook on May 8th now after Bishop to
b7 attacking the Queen Queen to g3 again
your knight is attacked you can do
captures captures the Queen defends the
pawn on e5 and after Knight to a5 Queen
to h4 attacking the knight and also with
a double attack against the bishop
Bishop captures with Czech Queen
captures attacking the knight and now
you can either try g6 with it which
isn't that great but to be far before
and now after captures captures nice
characters on e6 is the move that white
has that allows him to win this game as
his attack is coming much faster now
blacks queen is under attack you do have
to do something with the F pawn is
pinned you cannot capture it and after
Queen to b6 you get to disrupt to d8
check move and now you either have to
give up the Queen has black or you can
move the King and now you are in the
mating net Queen g5 check captures
Bishop c4 check there should be 5 and
Bishop captures on d5 this will be
checkmate so as you can see already on
move 9 a very sharp variation can arise
from the night off so if you want to
play the knight or if you really have to
know the lines and very well Knight bTW
7 by Fischer and now comes the Bishop to
d3 this Bishop to d3 move was the latest
theory development in how white can
pursue his advantage against the night
off
now b5 this is now playable we have rook
H 2 e 1 and now Bishop to b7 by Fischer
if you try something like before then
Knight to d5
we'll still be an idea for example he
captures he captures you will open up
the e-file where black will not be able
to castle as the King now has the guard
the bishop and white will have a very
very promising game here this night is
coming to c6 at some point and it will
be very very hard to play for black so I
have to look H e1 Bishop to b7 by
Fischer and now comes Queen to g3
Spassky simply keeps improving his
position a little by little although
there was a game there was a move Knight
to d5 here it was even played in the
game of le meter which reverses blue boy
of each where Knight captures was played
he captures on d5 and after Bishop
captures here at valley mirror which has
the mirror which is the person to do
this would did play rook captures on e6
would check pawn captures and now comes
Knight captures on e6 and even though it
seems black is falling apart black can
actually defend this he simply moves the
Queen Queen to b6 and after Queen to h5
check now comes g6 Queen captures a
sorry first Bishop captures and g6 would
check now comes King e7 Queen captures
on g5 and now after Knight to f6 black
seems to have defended and now all he
has to do is bring his rocks into the
game and why it doesn't seem to have a
way to keep attacking here so although
seems to be a very dangerous position
for black black can in fact defend so
Queen to g3 by Spassky we have queenside
castle by Fischer as now Knight to d5
will no longer be an option here and the
now comes Bishop captures on f6 and
Knight captures on f6 Bishop captures on
f6 would be too dangerous here spots
could simply play Bishop captures on b5
and now if pawn captures then you get to
Knight captures here attacking the Queen
and after the Queen moves Knight
captures an D sex with check King moves
and now even he 5 is coming you attack
the Bishop Bishop e7 and now even Knight
captures on f7 with a double attack
against the two rooks and here black is
really falling apart so after Bishop
captures on f6 we have Knight captures
on f6 by Fischer and now Queen captures
on g7
Spassky snatches a pawn here and it
seems to be it seems that it works
we have rook
rook to f8 you do have to protect the f7
pawn you can fall out Queen captures
here and then Queen cap trips here and
now simply Queen back to g3 so Spassky
decided that he in fact does have the
time to play Queen captures on g7 and
then go back to g3 but of course this
allows Fischer to play before attacking
the knight and now comes Knight to a4 by
Spassky rook H to g8 attacking Spassky
screen and now Queen to F do we have 9th
to d7 Fischer is removing his pieces to
place them on the ideal squares when you
were playing the knight of queen a king
to be won a very nice prophylactic move
and now comes King to b8 i also a very
nice prophylactic move by Fischer as
going immediately for Knights to c5
Knight captures pawn captures and now
knife can simply go back c4 Bishop is
coming to e2 and now again with ideas of
Queen coming to a7 you would have to
waste a move with King to b8 so before
going into all of this Fischer simply
improves the position King to b8 and now
comes to c3 as fast would like to open
the B files the C file so he can place
his rooks on the C file and now comes
the Knights to c5 attacking the
undefended night and a4 butter up the c2
defending the knight and now comes pawn
captures on c3 this is the correct idea
by Fischer because if you capture the
night then you get the bishop characters
on a4 and after pawn captures here and
now you get rook to see one Queen to a5
attacking spassky's Bishop but now comes
the bishop to c6 a very dangerous move
and now Bishop cannot capture because
Bishop captures would fork the king and
the Queen and after C capture C R now
you get Queen captures on b2 and now
black is lost you're threatening
checkmate here and after Queen moves to
defend it now you get bush of to a4 and
now as funny as it sounds
the queen is trapped the Queen has
nowhere to go the bishop is slicing
through this diagonal here the only
squares available to the Queen are a 5
and d8 here and it doesn't matter if you
go d8 or a5 Knight to c6 will win the
Queen as the bishop on B 7 is is pinned
so this is checked the queen is fork
you're going
who's the queen here same same applies
if you go here again it's check and you
lose the Queen so here after Bishop to
see to not Knight captures but rather in
immediately be captures on c3 Knight
captures on c3 and not Bishop to f6 and
Glitch mentions that here if we have a
opposition where blacks pieces are an
ideal squares for the night or something
seems to be wrong with the interface
here and but he is upon down so it's
hard to evaluate the position is this
Jeep on worse having four black or is
the open a semi open G file perhaps good
for black a very hard thing to decipher
but okay
g3 not allowing this rook to be a
dangerous piece and g8 we have h5 and
now comes a five Spassky
needs to do something and he goes for a
central breakthrough D captures on e5 f
captures on e5 and now Bishop to h8 you
cannot capture on e5 if you capture on
e5 then you get this very dangerous
knighted D to be five with an attack on
the Queen pawn captures Knight captures
and now after Queen to b6 you get rook
captures on e5 Queen captures and now
rook captures on c5 and white is winning
here regardless of what black plays you
have to move the Queen somewhere let's
say you move the Queen here but now you
get Queen f4 check King moves and now
rope to a5 check and here you're simply
getting checkmated even rook to a7 is an
idea to allow you to bring your pieces
in and the black will get to checkmate
it here so here Fischer goes to h8 and
now comes Knight back to f3
rook the d8 and here rook captures on
the 8th route capture Sundy 8th and 9th
to g5 Spassky has again play something
and he goes for the f7 pawn
Bishop captures on e5 and we have Queen
captures on f7 offering a queen trade
but now comes rock to d7 by Fischer and
here was a moment where Spassky most
likely had to play Queen e8 and be
satisfied with a draw after row b8 Queen
f7 rule d7 Queenie a truck d8 but
Spassky can't really use draws to get
back into this
so he plays Queen captures on h5 he
wants to win this game and Fischer now
takes his opportunity and ruins White's
pawn structure on the Queen side Queen
captures on c3b captors on c3 and now
Queen to b6 would check King to c1 and
now comes Queen to a5 attacking da to
pawn the c3 pawn and also preparing to
bring his beasties into the game one
idea being nice to d3 check we have
Queen to H a check by Spassky if you try
something like Knight captures on e6 -
with a double attack against Fischer's
night then Fischer will just laugh at
you with Knight to b3 check and you lose
the Queen as it's undefended on h5 so
after Queen to a5 we have King - a queen
- ETA 2 check King to a7 and now a 4 by
Spassky and here it seems that Spassky
is offering offering a pawn but as this
is game 15 in the match and since the
both of them are very tired
glitch mentions in his book that nice -
d3 the move Fischer plate is the best
way to go as it's very direct you want
to remove one of the defenders of whites
King and that a move like Knight
captures on a 4th it's very hard to
calculate there is no mate in sight and
it would be simply too dangerous but
it's very interesting the engine gives
Knight characters on a4 as straight to
winning like like there's no question
about it
giving the line Bishop captures the
Queen captures and now after White's
tries to bring his queen into the game
Queen a3 check King moves and now Bishop
to d5 what's the idea of playing Bishop
to e2 check and now after Queen to d4
check King has to move and now comes
well maybe not to b7 butts the b8 and
now rook to e8 a look to e2
preparing to defend this square and also
preparing a rook to be - to come with
check King to c8 and now look - D - but
now you would have Bishop to e2 check
rook captures and now Rock the b7 check
King moves and now Queen captures on a -
King either you will move the King for
example here and then you will
lose the Queen this way or you will
after Queen captures here you will move
the King here and then you will get
checkmated
but regardless a 4 doesn't work a knight
captures is a winning move for Fischer
here but Fischer goes for the human move
Knight to d3 check
we have Bishop captures rook captures
and now King to see to defending the a 2
point da 4 pawn because I was Queen
captures two King captures rook so you
don't have to do something about this
and still this is still a winning
position for Fischer but Fischer feels
that everything is winning here and it's
in fact very hard to find a defensive
idea here from black so Fischer played
rook to d5 here now defending the rug
Queen captures on a4 is coming but a
much better move would have been rook to
d7 would this move Fischer is completely
winning
however this rook to d5 move not so much
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move that saves the
position for Spassky I'll give you a
couple of seconds it's not an easy
decision to make as your knight and g5
is definitely hanging so feel free to
pause the video and try to defend this
with white for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
amazing defender of terrible positions
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
rook to e4 a very nice move by Spassky
he offers the night on g5 while
protecting the pawn on a4 and if this
rook went the d7 like we mentioned and
instead of on d5 then this move wouldn't
be possible and but Fischer didn't think
it was possible because the knight on d5
was under attack and here's the problem
a fluke captures then you have Queen to
d4 Czech Queen to b6 and now rook
captures on e6 Queen captures pawn
captures and here's Posse would have
three points for 4 for a piece and it
does seem that white will be able to
draw this game so after rook to a4 rook
to e4
rook to d8 was played by Fisher
attacking Spassky squeen on a date and
also opening up a discovered attack here
against the rook Queen to g7 only move
pins the bishop on b7 so the rook cannot
be captured now comes Queen to a5
pinning the rook but Spacely simply on
pins came to be three we'd have Queen to
d5 check King gay three and now Queen to
d2 Fisher is not preparing rook to d7 to
unpin attack the Queen and then Burton
captures rook is a possibility rook to
be for Spassky simply moves the rook and
now pressures Fischer's Bishop and b7
and also threatens checkmate we have
Queen to c1 check and it was in this
position that the game was adjourned so
the game will be continued tomorrow but
it was not a very long continuation of
the game after tomorrow at the
disposition the game resumed and a
couple of more moves were played rugby -
Queen e1 check roadblocks Queen c1 check
rugby - Queen e1 check and the game
ended so only three more moves were
played after at the continuation of this
journey game but still the the audience
gave them really really a huge applause
as it was again a very a very nice
fighting game and even though this game
and the previous game were draws you can
see how much how much fight there is in
these drawn games in this world chess
championship match
so yeah the result is now 933 point lead
and it will be very interesting how this
whole thing will end
I'll be back to the match with game 16
very soon I really hope you're enjoying
the coverage of this series so far I
would like to thank Paul Muller Chris
amico moon save Serie A software
properties and crispy card for a
contribution to my channel think you
ought to really appreciate it as usual
you can check - on my previous videos
your thing called for watching and I'll
see you soon
like I said it with hopefully with some
more interesting content thank you all
and I'll see you soon